[Music]
foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 190 nailed it
I'm Dr Brett Weinstein you are Dr
Heather Hein and we are raring to go
here on a cloudy drizzly Wednesday in
the beginning of September indeed yep
still summer but it doesn't totally feel
like it right now yeah I'll grant you
that yeah uh please come join us at
Rumble and locals we've got lots going
on our locals Channel
uh with watch party going on right now
for those of you tuning in live and
we're releasing guest episodes there a
day early we're doing our private q a
there uh Lots going on there so please
subscribe on Rumble for free and join us
at locals uh we truly appreciate and
there's lots to lots to do there uh we
are going to do a q a today after the
main live streams you can ask questions
at darkhorsesummissions.com
and as always we have sponsors uh who
help make this happen and we are very
appreciative of them our three sponsors
this week are Seoul mudwater and biome
and without further Ado I never know
what a do is but without any more of it
there's a lot of it right now for the
most part not not going into the Ado now
we are just going to go to the ads all
right fair enough
I first sponsored this week is Seoul
Soul footbed's the original custom
moldable insoles providing affordable
pain relief since 2001.
sole footbeds include a signature
supportive Arch that is great for any
Arch height if you have low arches or
flat feet you simply heat mold them in
your oven at home to ensure a
comfortable level of support
anecdotally I will say that sole
footbeds have been a game changer for me
I was born with weird feet weird enough
that I had reconstructive surgery on
both of them when I was 13 which put me
in a wheelchair for months and truly
really ridiculously ugly orthopedic
shoes for you there's no reason for them
to be that ugly there wasn't that
surgery was wildly successful small
market then no I didn't know you and I I
don't and I didn't I have never really
cared about shoes but even I could tell
these were really ugly shoes they were
bad yeah yeah and uncomfortable
um that surgery was wildly successful
however and I was playing Varsity Sports
within a couple of years of having it
but it's been a while since I was 13 and
my arches are beginning to flatten and
my feet hurt a lot more than they used
to wearing shoes with sole footbeds in
them is helping tremendously I have sole
footbeds in lots of my shoes now in my
extra tough boots hiking boots and even
in a nice pair of flats that you might
go to a nice restaurant in they have
multiple styles for different kinds of
activity if you have any foot issues at
all you seriously try these footbeds
sole footbeds are easily customizable
using your oven at or you can skip that
step and then mold to your feet over a
few days you get the benefits of
personalized support at a small fraction
of the price of doctor prescribed
Orthotics and they're made from recycled
quark
so all footbeds also reduce pain from
plantar fasciitis and shin splints they
promote neutral alignment and good
posture and are particularly effective
at preventing fatigue when standing or
walking for long hours on hard surfaces
which a lot of people have to do
two-thirds of people who try sole
footbeds come back for a second pair and
many have trusted soul to keep their
feet energized and pain-free for more
than 20 years if you've ever wondered
whether Orthotics could add to your
comfort or athletic performance this is
your best chance yet to find out why 17
million satisfied Souls already know
what they know
if uh I already read that part so is
giving away a thousand pairs of footbeds
to first-time customers simply go to
yoursoul.com Darkhorse or enter the code
darkhorset checkout to get a pair of
footbeds at only the cost of shipping
after the thousand free pairs of claimed
new customers will still get 50 off
their footbeds to claim a free footbed
go to your soul that's
y-r-u-r-s-o-l-e.com slash Darkhorse or
into the code Dark Horse at checkout
this offer ends October 31st try soul
footbeds today and find out how good
your feet can feel
yeah they're actually uh kind of
addicted as you know first first time
you put your foot on them and then it's
like oh I see why that that Ridge is
there yeah no it's they're they're truly
different and truly remarkable try them
our second sponsor this week is mud
water which makes truly delicious
products water makes a fantastic drink
it's spicy and delicious and chock full
of adaptogenic mushrooms and ayurvedic
herbs I think that's pronounced
ayurvedic not ayurvedic but whatever
whatever floats pronouncing it oh no I
think you had it right
with 1 7 the caffeine is a cup of coffee
you add energy without the anxiety
Jitters or crash of coffee if you like
the routine of making and drinking a cup
of warps in the morning but don't drink
coffee or are trying to cut down try mud
water if you're looking for a different
way to kick off your day with a
delicious warming enhancing way that
isn't just a caffeine Rush try mud water
each ingredient was added with intention
it has cacao and chai for just a hint of
caffeine lion's mane mushrooms to
support Focus cordyceps to help support
physical performance chaga and reishi to
support your immune system and cinnamon
which is a potent antioxidant but water
also makes a non-dairy creamer out of
coconut milk and MCT and a sweetener out
of coconut palm sugar and lucuma which
is the fruit of an Andean tree that was
used by the Inca to add if you prefer
those options or you can mix and match
add a bit of their coconut milk and MCT
creamer with some honey
from bees or use mud Waters lucuma and
coconut palm sugar sweetener and skip
the bees entirely mud water is also 100
USDA organic non-GMO gluten-free vegan
and kosher certified
mudwater flavor is warm and spicy with a
hint of chocolate plus Masala chai which
includes Ginger and cardamom nutmeg and
cloves it's also delicious blended into
a smoothie I had one just this morning
I had it with banana and ice and some
yogurt and a touch of honey and cacao
nibs and some strawberries and it was
amazing to get 15 off go to mudwater.com
darkhorsepod to support the show or use
code darkhorsepod for 15 off
all right our final sponsor this week is
biome maker of knobs n-o-b-s knobs is a
new kind of dentifrus dentifrus is
anything you use to clean your teeth
toothpaste or powders or knobs knobs are
fantastic biome that's biome without the
e on the end is focused on transparency
safety efficacy and efficiency yes they
are different and knobs is a truly
fenced excuse me truly fantastic product
let's talk fluoride fluoride is the
anti-cavity ingredient in most
toothpaste that you already know about
but as we discussed in our book The
fluoride and drinking water is not in a
molecular form that is found in nature
or that has ever been part of our diet
and Evermore research is pointing to
neurotoxicity from fluoride exposure
especially in children knobs from biome
does not contain fluoride but unlike
competitor products knobs does include a
different and far better re-mineralizing
agent which should be called Agent 99.
knobs uses hydroxyapatite hydroxyapatite
is the main component of the enamel in
your teeth
and it is in your bones as well it is as
effective as fluoride and remineral
re-mineralizing teeth without the
toxicity of fluoride hydroxyapatite
doesn't merely stop cavities from
forming it can even arrest tooth decay
once it is underway knobs also has no
abrasives like charcoal or baking soda
and also has no sulfites parabens
phthalates microplastics no BS it's
right there in the name furthermore
knobs comes in the form of dehydrated
tablets which allows them to be shelf
stable without any preservatives take a
tablet chew it a few times and brush as
normal your teeth are going to feel
fantastically clean because they are
also unlike with toothpaste TSA has no
interest in knobs because they're
tablets
so if you're flying with knobs you don't
risk losing your dentifrus in security
so check out knobs at
www.betterbiome.com
Darkhorse remember that's biome without
the e
b-e-t-t-e-r-b-i-o-m.com slash Darkhorse
listeners can enjoy 15 off their first
one month supply of knobs so go to
www.betterbiome.com
Darkhorse now to discover a great new
way to clean your teeth
[Music]
I did okay great sponsors as usual
and um there are a number of things to
talk about today do you want to start
why don't you start really yeah I
thought okay I thought as I could ask
you to start
okay nope I think we have reversed the
order for technical reasons that are
okay above my pay grade oh are they yes
that's fascinating
um
well I wanted to mention uh that uh Jill
Biden has tested positive for covid
um but
um and there's a
remarkable article I'm sure there are
many remarkable articles about about
this fact uh including in the telegraph
which is of course a British paper uh so
I I find it maybe more interesting to
read news about the US from non-american
sources they sometimes have a a better
view on things a a more nuanced at least
less you know embedded in the in the
problem uh view on things but I I guess
before we go there I also wanted to say
that my Natural Selections this week I
wrote about uh Joe Biden
Joe Biden's husband I remember him yeah
yeah uh Joe Biden's campaign slogan
which I only came to be aware of this
week which is together we can finish the
job
now that's extraordinary yeah isn't it
and I do I encourage you guys to go
check out my Natural Selections piece on
this I compare it to Reagan who I was
never any fan of back back in the days
um slogan uh which was it's morning in
America that was one of his ad campaigns
it's morning in America and it seemed
ridiculous at the time what the hell is
he talking about he hasn't done anything
good for the country of course you look
at some of the numbers now and you think
oh yeah okay
I've had some of that wrong you know he
did he did turn some stuff around of
course some of the stuff that he turned
around uh might have been the result of
skulldugger in order to get him elected
in the first place you know this is true
but
regardless of whether or not you think
that Reagan's America was in fact
morning in America
uh it was hopeful it was forward
thinking it was saying we are born again
here we are let's go forward let's do
something amazing and together we can
and let's finish the job
so as I write about in Natural
Selections this week like what what job
is that Joe
just you know fully selling out the
Americans to Big Pharma
um reducing with apologies to Governor
norquist reducing the size and influence
of science so that you can drown it in a
bathtub that's a fair point right I mean
it's just like what really we're gonna
finish the Gen then what
well if you think about the comparison
between the two men it's actually pretty
dramatic right now both I would argue
and
don't leap out of your seats but I would
argue that both men were actually
are actually in the case of Biden
figureheads that these people are
obviously not in charge of policy
um and in Reagan's case his purpose was
to provide a commanding presence
um that uh made policy changes that it
might otherwise not have been possible
possible and whatever you think of those
policy changes the idea that a
figurehead has a purpose and that
purpose is uh the you know the image
that the nation casts into the world for
example I remember my grandmother
swooning over him she remembered him as
a Hollywood star as you know b-list
actor whatever he was never huge but he
was handsome and dashing he's like oh I
get to vote for him so that you know
that was part of what the appeal was
right you could read lines and in
Biden's case he's about as commanding as
Bonzo the Chimp in the movie for which
Reagan is so uh famously derided yes
Bedtime for Bonzo is that it Bedtime for
Bonzo yes um this is so far before our
time that I am certain neither you nor I
have seen that film but
um but in any case actually uh you you
didn't happen to see a Dave Smith comedy
routine uh in which he argues that he
loves Joe Biden
um because Biden is almost a perfect
description of the state of the nation
this tissue paper thin individual
um which anyway it's a pretty funny
routine but the you know Biden uh you
know he can barely command his own show
news right he just he's not in a good
State and the idea that for some reason
even as ridiculous as it was to elect
him the first time we're staring down
the barrel of
having him in election a second time and
that the slogan which actually
um
it's a great contrast to Reagan's slogan
but it reminds me an awful lot of George
Bush seniors slogan
you remember that
did you run across it no I mean as it
turns out that there are often many
slogans and so like yeah it's morning in
America I don't think it was Reagan's
official slogan that was just that one
ad campaign right
um so I don't know the one I remember I
mean and you know uh George Bush Senior
was a lot of things but memorable he
wasn't
um as I actually before you tell us as I
as I say in the in the beginning of this
piece that I uh wrote this week
um
the it's morning in America ad campaign
uh uh was you know much derided in
Liberal circles in 1984 and of course we
were too young to vote in that election
but in 1988 which was the first election
that both you and I could could vote in
uh at the point that bush got elected I
wore a it's morning
m-o-u-r-n-i-n-g in America a pin around
campus just feeling very dark it felt
like such dark times and oh boy was it
not spy comparison to where we've gone
to yeah my spelling at the time was not
good enough for that pin but you know um
yeah it's a it's a it's a good one so
his campaign well I don't know I don't
actually remember if it was his slogan
but he was famously associated with the
idea
stay the course
oh yes he said that I think maybe he
said that in a debate and then it got
picked up in some ads or something stay
the course because like the
minimum possible argument in favor of
something is that changing course is bad
well I mean
literally
not exciting for sure
um but I mean I think I think it's some
if you really are at a time of plenty if
the country really has been turned
around especially if it's under your
president's watch and you were his VP
yeah and you know I don't I don't think
in retrospect almost any historian would
argue that 1988 was that moment but you
know there were certainly a lot of good
things going on in the country right
then but if that was really the moment
that you were in
um you you might compellingly argue you
know what I I was here for the last
eight years I you know helped I helped
this happen and I can therefore continue
to to do more in the same direction
because boy are we on the right on the
right course yeah I agree it was so I
mean look
I don't like politics at all politics is
the the malignant portion of policy
making and so I don't I don't have
patience for any of this stuff but the
idea that there's some version of
slogans that we remember that is
um that is optimistic and Visionary and
then there's some set of slogans that is
so bureaucrat bureaucratic and empty
that it's just hard to imagine what they
were thinking even if this is the
argument we should stay the course
because the course is pretty good and
you know don't let the perfect be the
enemy the good or whatever it is well I
mean it also seems like uh it is pretty
classic conservative right right what
we're doing is working why would we
change so I don't I guess I don't see
you know I'm not inspired by it but I
don't see that it's
an error inherently in the same way that
I feel like let's finish the job
and I didn't I you know I didn't spend
20 hours at the task but I went looking
like what do they perceive the job is
and you know it's
that what does he think he's done in his
first term
oh I well obviously
nothing about this has anything to do
with him this is some I don't it doesn't
matter him the Democrats team Blue Team
all of it but you know the the arguments
about what it is they have actually done
mostly are actually the opposite of what
has happened well we're going to get
into a thing here but the fact is they
have done something
and it's the same thing that they've
been doing for 30 years they Stave off
the French Revolution Moment by creating
distractions and creating false villains
and right but Stephen so Stephen off the
French Revolution moment isn't a job
no no finish the job how do you finish
saving off that's exactly the point this
is not about us so the idea is what are
we going to say to the people who are in
danger of revolting in order that we can
explain why we have no vision why we
don't accomplish things that matter why
we don't make the obvious plays that
would make the public happier because
that's no longer what this party uh is
about so I really do think this is about
you know just as when a political party
decides to attack education because they
aren't Downstream of public education
I'm not saying this is what's happening
presently but when a party decides hey
actually I don't really want the uh
children of my competitors well educated
because that will make them more
effective at competing with my children
so I'm going to sabotage public
education I'm going to subsidize my kids
education privately I'm going to argue
for
vouchers to recover as much of my
investment in publication as I and
public education as I can when you do
that you can't say let's sabotage our
competitors so you have to say something
in as an explanation for why you're not
doing the obvious thing which is
figuring out how education should work
and investing in it and I think this is
just one of these cases these people are
and you know I don't mean the Democratic
party but the people who run it are
enemies of the citizenry and therefore
it's difficult for them to explain
what they're doing and so of course an
empty slogan is like well you're going
to need a slogan
um and no slogan matches what they're up
to know I don't I guess I don't I don't
find that to be an answer but second
something what do you find if you go to
the White House social media accounts is
that for the last uh you know two years
three years
um they have been constantly posting
statistical things that are if not
outright lies extremely misleading and
misrepresentative yeah so they they
would have us believe that the economy I
believe that they would almost believe
that the economy is doing staggeringly
well yeah and um the prime rate is
nearly or depending on exactly like
basically double what it was when Biden
took office the prime rate no one could
get a mortgage like working class in
most middle class people can't afford a
mortgage when the when mortgage rates
are over eight percent
eggs are up electricity is up everything
is more expensive and yet we are being
told exactly the opposite by these
people so the finish the job is like oh
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna keep
on helping the middle class be able to
afford great things no you're doing the
opposite but you know I look I knew this
was going to tangle us but the fact is
they have one argument for reelecting
this guy
what's the one
right so
you can't say elect us because Trump
sucks worse right that is not a slogan
you need something that explains why you
didn't have a slogan and the main reason
you didn't have a slogan is because the
only thing that you could plausibly be
accomplishing is keeping the boogeyman
out of the office right no and actually
the the uh the campaign video on Biden's
site on the presidential reelection
campaign site which includes the tagline
which includes let's finish this job
he's slurs so he sort of says this
rather than the because he slurs because
he's ancient but it literally begins
with footage and doom music about from
January 6th right so I mean like that is
clearly the only reason that they
actually want you to know what but but
again that's not a job you can finish
you can't finish not election oh no no
no first of all whatever the hell is
going on with the weaponizing of the
courts against Trump this is a job that
they could plausibly finish now I think
they are absolutely insane to be doing
so maybe maybe that maybe that is a wink
yeah maybe it is a wink and the um let's
face facts
this is
I'm not a good enough historian to say
the weakest candidate who has ever been
run by a major party but as weak as he
was the last time he's even weaker right
right even weaker and more Despicable
and the have we know more about his his
career which was completely evident but
he is still
the most likable guy on the party
this guy who isn't likable at all is
still the most likable guy on the party
and that tells you something
they've gotten rid of all the decent
people so that's not true who Newsom no
I mean I mean for one thing Bobby
Kennedy is still a Democrat
um he is but as I keep pointing out they
are more afraid of Bobby Kennedy than
they are of I understand but you just
made the claim that Biden is the most
likable Democrat on offer well let's put
it this way he is the most likable
Democrat that the people who refuse to
give up their Stranglehold over this
once important party could possibly run
no I think it's some kind it's it's like
the the
the union of likable and controllable
he's completely controllable he's in no
position to do anything of his own but
anyway I did want to point out the
really direct parallel between stay the
course and finish the job like it's
almost the same formulation as morning
in America and make America great again
are very reminiscent of the same concept
right and you know as you point out it's
interesting that this nominally liberal
president and he's only nominally
liberal what he really is is just
corrupt and using the echo of liberalism
as a disguise but that this is now a
very conservative uh statement with no
vision whatsoever it is yeah it's a it's
a con it's hearkening back to yesterday
which was perhaps actually nominally
better than today and whose fault is
that yes and it's also terribly ironic
because
um
the most important thing that we could
say about the Democratic party and its
value between when it was a defender of
slavery and its current instantiation as
a wickedly corrupt shadow of its former
self but in its Heyday this party
actually Advanced policies that were in
the interest
of working people and those policies
actually completed a liberal vision of
the way the West should run and the way
the West should run is that it should be
interested in uh color blindness equal
protection under the law everybody
having a fair access to the market all
of those liberal principles which the
Democratic party is now savaging right
and this is actually a little back and
forth we had in the comments on my
Natural Selections piece someone pointed
out exactly this like the parties have
effectively reversed right what they
stand for
uh and you know this is this is exactly
what you're saying and and what we've
said before but
um most voters haven't caught on yet or
at least most blue voters haven't caught
on yet that the Republicans are actually
the ones standing up for the gains of
yesterday which were mostly put into
motion by uh radicals and liberals and
hippies and such and Democrats right and
the Democrats are busy working really
hard to dismantle all of those games yes
in fact I'm working really really hard
to make us hyper aware of things like
race that we were you know we weren't
done with it but we were definitely
headed in the right direction hyper
aware of race dismantling uh women's
rights by pretending that men are women
and I it's it's remarkable and
like I don't
how much brand loyalty could you
possibly have to maintain blinders that
make you think that today's Democratic
party is the same one as that of the 60s
right you know put aside the question of
corruption Perhaps Perhaps both parties
have been corrupt the whole time
certainly there's been some corruption
in both parties the whole time
but in terms of what they were actually
really working towards and standing for
what the Democrats stand for and we're
working towards in the 60s has no
relationship to what is happening now
it has yeah it's a it's an ironic
sabotage of all of the the good stuff
that was accomplished and uh frankly
that's why some of us are so freaking
pissed off about it
um but I would also point out there's an
obvious tactic here
the
um
creating of a narrative around January
6th and around Donald Trump
is about getting your amygdala to do the
voting right that's what they have to do
because if it was your conscious mind
rationally considering who these people
are and what they're doing and what it
means to your future is no conceivable
way that anybody would support it and
the reason that people do support it is
because they have been uh whipped into a
frenzy of fear over Trump and over the
idea that something like a coup almost
unfolded on January 6th and whatever is
true a the obvious involvement of
the FBI
in January 6th means that anybody who
thinks they know what happened really
has to take a step back and rethink it
yeah and and I mean
this is the point we've made over and
over and over again but meanwhile what
happened
um to the people holding cities like
Portland hostage for months at a time
nightly riots every single night that
any of these people seen Justice
right and uh you will no doubt recall
that I wanted to see both groups
pardoned that's right because
um
the the necessity for us to get out of
letting our amygdala be the deciding
factor in elections is so great that um
it would I mean it would have been a
slam dunk and you know that was the
Patriotic thing to do was to say all
right
we've seen stuff on both sides it's
unacceptable but we are not going to
tear ourselves apart
um sorting it out sending people to jail
and especially you know the comparison
is so clear I mean frankly that would be
a gift to the left
and instead the left has been like nah
we're just going to pretend that none of
that crap happened at all on our side
yeah and it was it went on
for
a tremendously long time some of the
cities are still under its sway I mean
Portland is yep and and there's just
that you know it's mostly peaceful
they're mostly sane they're mostly
dressed they're mostly not on fentanyl
they're mostly like what yeah no it's
nonsense and it went on it was you know
if it wasn't premeditated on the first
night it was premeditated for the you
know 99 nights after that that's right
um and that's very different than a
one-off event where you know actually
the story we were sold is
in conflict with the video which they
didn't show us in which you know people
who've been locked away in a jail cell
were being about which one are you
talking January 6th
um where you know you had you had this
uh
uh the Q Anon Shaman guy and I probably
shouldn't be using that term because I
think it was part of the the psyop but
where he's being you know LED around by
the capital police inside the building I
mean
this none of this makes any sense but
um
anyway I do think we the public would be
really wise to stop letting them uh
trigger our reflexes because our
reflexes are not good at thinking and
this amygdala stuff
um is getting a lot of people who would
ordinarily look at Joe Biden and say
you've got to be crazy that's the
candidate but of course you know
with you know the boogeyman as the
alternative it's like well you know
you know and that's that's the only way
that he can win again is if uh Trump is
his competitor
yeah and they're and I don't know you
certainly can't win against Bobby
no he well not a fair fight not a fair
fight if the thing takes place in the
Democratic party then I don't see I
don't see how Bobby could get the
nomination right the thing is but but in
a general election yep oh yeah um
the only possible chance that Biden has
of winning in a fair fight is against
Trump yep and
um of course that presumes that a fair
fight is possible yeah
all right so um
oh hold on uh Jill Biden has tested
positive for coven 19. Jill you said you
said yes yeah yes
um
and here we have the telegraph with a
you know remarkably youthful-ish you can
show please
um
totally competent looking president
there and uh happy looking Jill and
um what were oh is that all I get now oh
they shortened this since I saw it last
um
we have
uh
they're considered in a high risk group
because of their age
but both have been vaccinated
as if that's helpful which is not and
then
um two paragraphs up from there in this
very short piece Mrs Biden 72 last
tested positive for the virus in August
last year after Mr Biden himself
recovered from the same illness
last test a positive this is just what
we do because we all understand
that vaccines provide no protection at
all against disease but they just make
you kind of roll with the punches
okay so and this is this is both old
news and even the telegraph which is not
a particularly left-leaning paper at all
is just it's just becoming background
it's at least they're
vaccinated well the last time she got uh
coveted was just a little more than a
year ago
um what were other shots
about well I I have to tell you
um this is one of these stories that I
for reasons of keeping my analytical
sanity
uh do not process because I'm not
confident
that it means that any of the things
about the story are true if they thought
it was in their interest to portray Jill
Biden as
sick with covid and recovering I have no
doubt they would do it sure
um
I do not trust that Jill Biden or Joe
Biden
got the same vaccinations as Citizens
right so so you your resp keep going but
you are responding to a very different
level of the story than I'm responding
to the media reporting on it and what it
leads people to believe about
um the normalization of well of course
she got coveted everyone gets covered
like well what were the shots for then
and well of course she's not going to
get sick because of course she's
vaccinated so both of those things exist
with a couple lines of one another in
this mainstream Outlet right and I do
process that part of the story that the
um utility of the story right is in
reporting it just so right she got it
she's not very sick of course she was
vaccinated
um and I can see why that narrative
would be useful because of course we
know lots of people who are getting sick
with it
um mostly vaccinated
and the the
obvious ghost in this machine
is whatever Anthony fauci was doing that
created the problem in the first place
denied us remedies that worked and then
sold us a one-size-fits-all remedy that
didn't work and so
um what we should be doing is saying
okay if this is the new normal and
people are now just simply getting this
disease on the regular and whatever you
think of it you may think it's not a big
deal you and I think it's a bigger deal
than people think it is because of some
of the uh long-lasting effects of it the
broad range of tissues that it infects
and things like that that the costs of
the errors that were set in motion by
fauci and his friends is gigantic with
no end inside this isn't this is
something we're going to indefinitely
pay costs over and so we should be very
focused on how this happened and what we
can do to make sure it doesn't happen
again and we appear to be
um very lightly focused there if at all
yes
so covet also seems to have hit the US
Open
one of the the grand slam the one of the
big four tournaments in tennis
and the New York Times asks and you may
show my screen why are so many players
getting sick at the US Open
um just a few a few bits from this so
many so many people sick but largely
it's not being attributed to covid and
the New York Times is kind of going like
oh we don't know well you're not
required to get vaccinated anymore so
maybe
um as if that would have prevented it
from being there um but you're also not
required to be tested so how would we
know well not that the tests are any
real any good anyway but it seems odd
that they are almost like pretending
that you wouldn't be able to tell
um when for so long for a couple of
years it was all about for sure anytime
anyone is sick it's definitely coveted
even though yeah you kind of actually
can't tell so here we have
um you know just a number of people sick
it's not just players the ESPN
commentator John Mcenroe said on Tuesday
that he had he see it he's the one
person in the story who actually tested
positive for the coronavirus after
feeling unwell but again the tests are
unreliable in both directions it is
unclear whether all of the players have
the same illness or whether their cases
are connected but something has been
going around the US Open well that
sentence alone is incoherent because if
something is going around the US Open
it's connected and if it's some things
if you know it's also extraordinarily
unlikely that unlike any past year a
whole lot of players are getting very
sick sick enough to have to
um stop stop matches
um that it's completely unrelated
they're all independent cases like you
know that's that doesn't seem like it
seems like a contagious disease it seems
like a contagious saving like a
contagious disease exactly it is I would
point out
and I would love to have the
retrospective data on this the
pre-covered data but one of the things
that seems to be true
is that there's a lot of out of season
illness now of course summer colds were
always a thing right but not but this is
these are this is worse than a cold here
yeah yeah um and so anyway there there
is a question about you know what
what was in Pandora's Box that they
released what is the effect of this and
how much of it is them trying to Spook
Us by as they obviously did utilizing
lots of phenomena that weren't coveted
and lumping them in with coveted deaths
and and all of this
um so what game are they playing now
that's what I wanted like okay so the
game has changed what game is it now
guys like what what are you up to what's
the point now what is the job that you
are trying to finish New York Times so
here's just a couple more things from
this this article in New York Times
illnesses are possible at any tournament
where players are often in close
quarters and share facilities but with
players no longer required to test for
covid-19 it is difficult to determine
the cause of the illnesses among them
again like testing for kova 19 if we
actually had good tests even if they did
that unless it was positive you still
wouldn't have any more information about
what else they might have
but they're also not good tests and by
the way why not like why do we still not
have good tests that's a question Health
protocols at the US Open have become
less stringent since 2020 when
Spectators were not allowed to attend
the tournament and when players took the
empty courts in face masks
stringent is one word for it insane is
another right like you had you had Elite
athletes playing in face masks
across a freaking tennis court from one
another with no one in the stands well
it didn't mean they could strangle at
each other with uh without violating any
rules of etiquette good Lord when fans
were allowed to return in 2021 they were
required to show proof of vaccination
against the coronavirus yes they were
that requirement has since been dropped
and those attending the US Open this
year do not need to show proof of
vaccination provide a negative
coronavirus test or wear masks
um
and then this uh young woman Jabor I'm
not totally sure ANS Jabor uh who was
seated like five or something
um got really really sick she says I'm
taking a lot of medicine she said adding
that she basically took every medication
the U.S open doctors have
great good for her why isn't she getting
well when she's taking all the medicine
the doctors recommend yeah geez I wonder
what it is how does she get to be an
elite athlete doing that I'm a Zombie
because I have a flu
so this whole thing just feels like yet
another well psyop honestly like you
know that sounds we got one person the
problem you know one of the most famous
people at the tournament who's now a
commentator John Mcenroe
um having actually tested positive and
having all the symptoms that we are told
are currently associated with the
current brand of covid that we have been
sold and yet these other people are
assured that they have the flu we're
walking like I I just
how how is anyone continuing to believe
any of the stories from these people
well I want to go back to the
conspicuous fact of us not having
reliable tests right
um
the fact that the tests have not gotten
substantially better over time
is conspicuous yeah and the degree to
which the people playing this game have
been interested in
creating narratives that were not
supported by evidence but were very
difficult to fight because it wasn't
like you could say here's the evidence
and it doesn't match your story because
the evidence was confused by all this
noise so in other words is it possible
that really noisy covid tests are a
feature and not a bug because it allows
you to claim anything at any moment
right and is that is you know I I do
think I I have a sense of foreboding
around the upcoming 14 months
that the U.S presidential election
is
uh going to create a
um a fertile landscape for psychological
operations of many times we're going to
have many claims of missed this and Mal
information over
presumably true things will be dismissed
false things will be portrayed all of
the usual stuff and
the ability to have a viral Boogeyman
that you can call forth at any moment by
declaring that some set of illness is
this thing
may be the reason that the tests aren't
any good because if we you know if you
could just simply go to CVS and buy a
test that was reliable enough that you
know it really gave you a confidence
that you either did or didn't have the
thing then we'd be in a very different
place because we would actually be able
to generate information about what is or
isn't circulating yeah that's right
um
so
in unrelated news novakia Djokovic is
playing he's seated two it's
interestingly not one and he's wiping
the floor with his opponents there's
lots of people who aren't sick at the US
Open he's not the only one but he of
course is famously unvaccinated was not
allowed to play in earlier U.S open and
Australians I think
captured him and had him and like in in
one of their little
enchantments yes
um despite being well despite despite
being well
um you know so well in fact that he
refused uh to take a um experimental
treatment for a disease which if he got
he would be very likely to fend off
because of his Youth and vigor yes and
the treatment would be very likely or
too likely to Rob him of his elite
athletic status by virtue of a mechanism
that we will talk about a little later
in the podcast yeah
so um
not surprising that he's continuing to
wipe the floor with his opponents but uh
yes it is a little surprising to me
because we have known since early in the
pandemic that wiping the floor doesn't
help since this is not transmitted by
fomite
okay
I thought that was a pretty good joke no
I don't I don't think so
um all right well
so the attempt was made as the kids say
the world socialist website
has an opinion about what's happening in
the U.S open as well
U.S Open tennis players Fall by the
wayside as covid surges
this is uh
the the first paragraph is amazing and
I'm just going to read the first
paragraph and then the final paragraph
of this piece from the world socialist
website this year's U.S Open tennis
tournament in New York City has been
plagued by what is being euphemistically
referred to as a mysterious illness and
what in fact is all the Hallmarks of a
covid-19 super spreader event
a number of top players had to pull out
of the tournament or have struggled to
play due to covet-like symptoms
including respiratory and
gastrointestinal ailments actually one
more paragraph here the Spate of tennis
player is getting sick takes place under
conditions for the United States tennis
Association and the U.S open organizers
have dismantled all anti-coveted safety
measures in the midst of a new Global
surge of the pandemic this is the first
hidden surge of the pandemic since the
World Health Organization and the Biden
Administration ended their covid-19
Public Health Emergency declarations in
early May which cleared the path for the
scrapping of all pandemic surveillance
and public health measures globally we
just check out the language there right
the scrapping of all pandemic
surveillance the scrapping of
surveillance yes how dare they scrap the
surveillance
dare they scrap the scrappy surveillance
that didn't work with the scrap in the
first place amazing right and so like
this piece is long and remarkable and
I'll link to it in the show notes and
all but here
here is the final paragraph more
fundamentally the criminal cover-up of
the pandemic and the unchecked spread of
covid-19 must be opposed with a
socialist public health program in
non-metric opposition to the monstrosity
unfolding at the U.S open what is
required is a powerful mass movement of
the international working class in unity
with public health workers and
scientists to force the implementation
of a global elimination strategy to stop
all human to human transmission of
covid-19 throughout the world
oh man this was written now
yeah this is this week this is the US
Open happening right now this is the
world socialist saying
what is required is to force the
implementation of a global elimination
strategy it is
almost a
perfect description of how a Marxist
would think about this like independent
of the biology the implausibility of
what it is they are proposing Force must
be used to get us to unite around doing
away with this virus that we're going to
be stuck with for the rest of Eternity
right I mean you know from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need and if we have to
lock you in your houses and get your
neighbors to rat on you in order to make
it happen then so be it
I mean right total the communism in a
nutshell so it's amazing they're not
even accomplished they're socialists
like it's not it's not even I I'm just
I'm just shocked that anyone puts this
um puts this in writing I mean like okay
one more throughout the world the vast
majority of the population can no longer
receive free or affordable covid-19
testing treatments like Pax lovid and
even vaccines will soon only be
available at marked up prices
people who are these people they're
they're like they're like commies in bed
with Pharma like Pharma you know they're
pharmac what the hell this is it's it's
nuts it's totally nuts and I I don't
know I guess I guess just that it's
totally nuts what that they would put
that up and apparently have no sense of
irony or embarrassment yeah how about
workers of the world unite around not
getting taken for a ride by this
anymore I mean you know we we wake up
the world you're not here
yeah wait I mean this is just obvious
right they're on the wrong side of
history and they can't figure it out
yeah yeah
um
one more thing before we go into what
you want to talk about uh the connection
is Just Tennis but it's not about covid
it's that Martina Navratilova uh has who
you know another a contemporary of John
Mcenroe although of course they didn't
play against one another because
um neither of them pretended to be the
sex that they were not and that wasn't
really that allowed then anyway although
there was
um
one one such case uh in the 70s or 80s
when both of them were playing she has
been speaking out against uh Men playing
in women's sports and she has written a
piece now published at genspect uh which
is a fantastic organization uh that is
having a conference in November that I
will be at
uh in in Denver and
this was published last end of August
five years later what I've learned about
women and men in sports
and there's a there's a lot of good here
all right she is standing up for
um for for women to be able to play
against women in sports and she says
among in in part of her argument
um Serena Williams made the same basic
point when Grand Slam Champion Andy
Murray challenged her to an exhibition
match in 2013. she refused explaining to
David Letterman Andy Murray has been
joking about me and him playing a match
I'm like Andy seriously are you kidding
me if I were to play Andy Murray I would
lose six zero six zero the men are a lot
faster and they serve harder they hit
harder it's just a different game okay
uh I'm gonna skip that one for a moment
and then they then never tell over
writes the female category was created
to provide opportunities for women to
compete fairly it was always intend to
exclude males we need to keep excluding
them
and this is like she just says it so
clearly and simply and you know it's
it's it's one thing
to and you know put aside whether or not
I or you
um
think that this has gotten out of
control and may not be what we were sold
at all but it's quite one thing to say
I feel I'm a man but I feel more like a
woman and I'm going to dress that way
and I'd love it if you were to address
me that way
um
put aside what that might mean for that
person and Society
anyone pretending that putting on the
costume of makes you the thing is just
doing that pretending and this is being
used to erode
women's rights and frankly the the and
we've said this over and over to give
like women's sports is the piece that
matters the least right it just does I
care about women's sports a lot of
people do but it matters the least but
it's the most obvious place because
everyone can see everyone who is
physically active at all has ever
engaged in any kind of athletic
competition understands that men and
women are different and they're going to
be differently capable over in the
athletic Realm
so there's just there's one thing in
here
um that navratil ever wrote that I sort
of I threw an error at and I want I
wanted to point this out because
um it it goes into you know the Giant
Rabbit Hole of what is actually Title IX
and what does it what does it promise
so she writes the promise of Title IX
has not been realized 51 years after its
Inception according to a report by the
women's sports Foundation high school
girls enjoy 1.1 million fewer Sports
opportunities than boys do and college
women enjoy 80 000 fewer opportunities
than men Champion women Incorporated has
found that women lose out on 1.1 billion
dollars in college scholarship dollars
alone not to mention inequities and
sponsorships and media coverage
I want to focus on that um the
statistics that she's pulling from the
women's sports Foundation report which
I've got here too and I've skimmed but
the particular statistics that
Navratilova is pointing out here as
evidence that the promise of Title IX
has not been realized is that quote high
school girls enjoy 1.1 million fewer
Sports opportunities than boys do and
college women enjoy 80 000 fewer
opportunities than men
this is not evidence that Title IX has
failed this is not evidence that women
are being
um
treated unfairly this is not evidence
that there is bias against women in
sport
it can be true and there can it can also
be true and I'm not saying that we've
gotten there but this is not evidence of
bias
um because it is quite possible and I
would argue incredibly likely
that men are far more likely to be
interested in engaging in competitive
athletic sports than are women
and unless what you are arguing is that
men and women have to be exactly the
same with exactly the same interests and
the same outcomes and only then shall we
have achieved equality and of course
that's not equality that's equity
then
that's that's a ridiculous desire and I
went looking to see is that actually
what Title IX is is shooting for because
I thought the title I have seen Title IX
be weaponized for a long time now right
but I never thought that what it what it
was trying to do was get equal numbers
of male and female athletes because
that's a stupid goal right so what I
find is I'm sorry I have to pull it up
it's going to take me a moment here what
I find is
in this report that nabitalava is citing
this little graphic Title IX three-part
test of gender equity and athletic
participation opportunities and this I I
find is an actually accurate portrayal
of what Title IX offers
this is a three-part test in which
institutions that meet any of these are
found to be in compliance with Title IX
part one substantial proportionality
athletic participation opportunities for
girls or women and boy or men athletes
are offered at rates proportional to
their enrollment okay that's the one
that's the one that we just heard uh
Navratilova tried out those statistics
well you don't have you know at this
point we've got like 60 40 women to men
in many college campuses right so we
need to have 60 of the athletes be women
that's a stupid goal and that is one of
the ways that institutions could be
found to be in compliance with Title IX
but it's only one or number two history
and continuing practice of program
expansion offerings in the athletic
program have kept pace with increasing
numbers of girls and women athletes
cool
less operational like it's less easy to
see exactly what the metric is but that
sounds right
that sounds like yeah okay if if there
are women who are trying to play sports
there should be the offerings for them
to me that's what Title IX was about or
full and effective accommodation the
existing menu of teams offered satisfies
the interests and abilities of the
underrepresented sex
so two interesting things here first of
all that seems like the broadest most
doable and most actually honorable goal
of Title IX if there are you know if in
the early 70s there are a bunch of girls
in high school who really wanted to play
soccer and the response was girls don't
play soccer Title IX came to be in part
to help that to not be the response
actually we want to play soccer and if
we want to play soccer and you've got a
boys soccer team you got to put some
resources towards girls being able to
play soccer too at the high school level
or at the college level as well but the
other thing that's interesting here is
that it doesn't say the existing menu of
teams offered satisfies the interests
and abilities of girls and women it's
those of the underrepresented sex
so there may be some some sports that
are historically female dominated and
Title IX actually requires that if Boys
and Men start becoming interested in
some such Sports uh that there be a
movement to accommodate their interest
as well and you know this is this is
also you know people who don't
understand populations or teams might
get confused by the fact that like oh
well we can just find one person at some
school one one girl who wants to play
basketball and the fact that there's no
Women's Basketball team means that
they're not in compliance with Title IX
like you know what one person does not
make a basketball team
I don't know how many you need eight
maybe I mean I know five people are on
the court at a time but to make a team
you probably need seven or eight
something like that it's probably
usually uh deeper bench than that but
one person saying oh God title land has
failed because I don't get to do what I
want to do it's like well if what you
want to do as a team sport and no one
else wants to play with you that's not
about Title IX and the government should
have no say in forcing a bunch of other
girls or women to play with you because
you have a desire and frankly this feels
like in microcosm
the the entire Insanity going on on the
left with regard to like if I want to do
this thing I'm going to throw a fit
until I get someone from the government
to come make sure that I get what I want
and not only that but the reason that
there aren't others like me who want to
do this thing is obviously evidence of
highest discrimination racism sexism
obviously yeah where totally you know it
is not unlikely that for example girls
are less interested in playing football
right and I don't like I I wanted to and
I didn't have time to like okay are
there any women's football teams or do
women just not play football
right
um yeah I mean I I don't know and it's
obviously a self-reinforcing pattern
because to the extent that it isn't on
television and uh that there aren't lots
of programs means that girls who might
be interested in exploring it don't end
up doing it but
um I think it is pretty clear that at
least if you took a static snapshot that
the interest by girls and women in
playing football is going to be lower
well I mean
I mean if football's a good example
right I mean these are war games yeah
this this is this is the Olympics this
is this is
four show that we have a ready force
that can engage in competition for play
such that at some moment that we are
called upon to do so we will have ready
um Warriors yep right and there there
are a few and women don't engage in war
games right and they don't engage in war
in right virtually any culture at
virtually any time one because of the
other right and you know this particular
game is one that actually not for every
single player but at least across a team
does reward the very things that
distinguish men and women so differently
right the the weight and strength
Advantage is a primary player in
football whereas you know agility can
compensate for for it to an extent on a
basketball court and I don't know I
assume women's basketball has a
different basket height so you can just
simply neutralize the distinction I
don't know
um Zach knows
I don't know the answer to that but I
know that professional women's
basketball is famously boring to watch
so I think it may not be lowered to make
it
um okay famously boring isn't it I think
it may be the same game that is not very
welcome
I'm going to bed from an uninformed
position that the basket is lowered to a
different standard but in any case
um one more thing I didn't want to put
you on the spot yeah I am having trouble
remembering and I'm embarrassed which
player I can't remember yeah but the
famous match between Bobby Riggs and
Billie Jean King Billie Jean King that's
who it was yeah why does that never come
up in the arguments over the difference
between males and females in sport
yeah I mean it's I think
it does some and I think I think the old
guard mostly is just rolling their eyes
and hoping it will go away right like
they I think no one who's not paying
close attention to the trans ideology
Madness
actually can believe that it is has
gotten as far as it has
uh and and some people and I think I
think Navratilova started out here
frankly
um sees one thing and goes like oh well
that can't that can't be the case and
then finds herself dragged I think she
got dragged by that uh that trans
bicyclist I don't remember which one
there's so many of them now
um and she went looking you know she got
told to educate herself she's like okay
I'll go educate myself I I you know I am
only like one of the best female tennis
players of all time but okay I'll go
educate myself and you and also you know
out early as a lesbian before that was
easy at all or common at all so she's
you know she's she's been through all of
these ringers that are should be
relevant here and she wouldn't educated
herself and went like yeah no men
shouldn't be playing in women's sports I
am pretty sure that's obvious to
everyone and I think she you know like
like anyone who goes deep goes like whoa
I can't believe we're here but most
people are just like that oh not my
thing not my story I don't know I'm sure
there's truth on both sides I'm sure the
truth is somewhere in the middle well no
the truth is not always somewhere in the
middle not when you've got an antagonist
that is so powerful and so insane that
they move their position completely off
the playing field yeah and you can
always tell uh
who it is because the point is they
destroy the possibility of having a
nuanced perspective they destroy the
middle specifically so that we have an
argument that can't be can't be resolved
yeah yeah
okay I think um I think I'm done all
right
um well I wanted to talk about something
uh and I'll present sort of the the
general version of it but far too often
in the modern sense making landscape I
think that there is just a missing layer
and I'll start by quoting my friend
Steve Patterson who has been on the Dark
Horse podcast
who uh once said that philosophy is
where it's at philosophers aren't which
I think is really insightful and I I
will say it echoes my own annoyance at
the fact that we train people in
philosophy presumably lots of them we as
a society invest in this
and yet they are nowhere adjudicating
debates over evidence we have claims and
counter claims about uh global climate
change about covid about treatments
about Origins all these things
that is the right place for philosophers
who are actually good at figuring out
how to take uh irreconcilable Bodies of
Evidence and reconcile them so that we
can at least
um proceed in a rational way relative to
um to the signal that we can extract
from the noise you're looking for
Applied philosophers
right I think we should be drafting them
it should not be up to I'm sure they're
underemployed
well I think what they or do they not
exist anymore because they have not been
trained to actually do philosophy I
think there is a a grand error at just
sort of a standard academic error where
philosophers who
most of the time when there's nothing to
talk about
end up finding what to talk to each
other about and then they come to think
that that's their job is talking to
other philosophers rather than
adjudicating the really important stuff
of the day which would be a perfect
place for them to say here's how you
deal with this claim and this counter
claim right and that would be a
fascinating thing how many of us would
not benefit from seeing somebody who was
not a climate scientist come in and say
okay let me ask you some questions about
that claim you are making and let's see
whether it stands up based on you know
frankly a lot of ancient wisdom about
the nature of facts
so
philosophy is where it's at philosophers
are not because the philosophers are too
busy talking to each other to help the
rest of us out which is what they should
be doing which is presumably the reason
we initially subsidized the existence of
these fields in the first place
that that said what I think is missing
are some basic pieces of the puzzle
about
um assumptions
presumption about burdens of proof about
thresholds of proof and that these are
things that you know they're you know in
a court of law these things are all
thoroughly well understood because they
have to be right who has the burden of
proof well if you've been accused of a
crime the state has the burden of of
right you could in theory say nothing
and if the state cannot make a
compelling case that you committed the
crime you you walk free
you know what constitutes evidence the
idea that for example if the state has
violated your right to privacy and it
has discovered that you you know let's
say it discovers a letter that you have
written acknowledging that you committed
a crime and describing some of the
details that it is not only not allowed
to enter that letter into evidence
against you because it cheated to get it
it cheated and violated an important
right of yours but it is not allowed to
proceed from fruit of the poisonous tree
that is to say it cannot go back to the
letter and say well okay we can't use
the letter but what do we learn from the
letter that we could use actually
everything Downstream of it is poisoned
so these kinds of things are dealt with
in a formal context
in court but we out here in public
trying to figure out what to think about
what we're being told are uh not
benefiting from the fact that these uh
these things are actually well well
worked out so just to um
repeat I said slightly flippantly you
were looking for there to be applied
philosophers then you're now arguing
that actually law is applied philosophy
at a very formal level but that we need
effectively informal applied philosophy
in our in our daily lives and I I would
point out too that actually the you know
all of the degrees that people get which
then allows them to be teaching
undergraduates at University almost all
of them are in fact doctors of
philosophy
and while you might have a PhD in
biology for instance as we do or a PhD
in art history or a PhD in chemistry or
any number of other things all of those
are supposed to be doctors of philosophy
and whereas
our program our mentors actually took
that very very seriously and we were we
were infectively trained in the
philosophy of science
um throughout throughout our our
graduate work when I have said that to
other people with phds when I have said
well you know we are supposed to be
engaging in philosophical inquiry I have
received everything from quizzical looks
to outright laughter yeah they they
really
cannot imagine what the philosophy part
of the doctor of philosophy is doing
there yeah and
they because they have seen only
bastardizations of it or abstractions
that are so remote they couldn't
possibly be useful they do not
understand what role it plays when life
and limb are on the line and I would say
that actually one group a group I'm
pretty angry at at the moment but one
group has actually distinguished itself
in this Regard in recent history
and that's the rationalists the
rationalists because of their
relationship
um with Bayesian analysis have actually
formalized a branch of this and if
properly applied it is very very useful
I'm angry at them in large measure
because
they didn't understand that there was a
line that if they crossed it it was
going to ruin their Bayesian analysis
and I think the effective altruism
movement did not understand that it was
saying something painfully naive in
trying to take rationalism
into a an operationalizable
um position in other words I you know I
want the philosophers to tell us how to
think about stuff I don't want
um
that I don't want an army of
philosophers remaking Society I want
once we know uh how things should be
understood than we others are probably
better at figuring out what to do about
it
um but in any case
and frankly the absurdity of the way the
rationalists uh screwed up covid despite
a tremendous amount of evidence that
they should have processed properly is a
stunning failure
um you know hopefully they will
instead of doubling down they will wise
up and recover from that but
in any case
um so I wanted to point to the question
of when should
something like silence actually alter
what you think is likely going on and I
was spurred to think about this because
of a a happy accident a Confluence of a
couple things that happen close together
in time that I know to have been
unrelated because I was involved in one
of them
so many of the viewers of this live
stream will have seen the episode that I
did with Jeremy riss and Michael Sherman
and that is an episode that's very good
because we all agree on the objective of
uh of analytic work being discovering
what is true
and we have arrived at different
conclusions about what might be true and
and
um
anyway it's an interesting discussion I
strongly recommend people
watch it Zack do you have a clip I want
to show a clip from a particular segment
in which for long time viewers of the
podcast you will have heard me describe
a mechanism that I claim makes any mRNA
platform vaccine dangerous because it
um
will induce cells to produce a foreign
antigen which cannot help but trigger
the immune system to react to those
cells as if they are infected by a virus
which they are not and Destroy them
which will then do damage to whatever
organ was doing the Translating of that
protein
okay so here is my exchange after having
so explained that if the vaccine the
so-called vaccine stayed in your deltoid
when they injected it then the answer is
well the cells that will be attacked by
your immune system are in your arm and
you can afford to lose them once we knew
that the vaccine circulated around the
body it should be clear to anyone who
understands how immunity develops that
this is going to cause an autoimmune
disorder in any tissue that transcribes
it and if that tissue happens to be your
heart it's going to be a devastating
problem so how Paul offit doesn't know
that I think Paul Offutt has to know
that how did the other people who signed
off on this not know it but I don't know
he's not here I don't I don't even know
what you're talking about it's like you
know you float this hypothesis Jeremy
and I or we don't this is not what we do
so I don't even know how to you know how
is it possible not just Paul off it you
know this is like thousands of
scientists whatever okay either just
delusional or bought off or perfect
perfect we've got you can't evaluate
what I said nor should you be able to
you're not a biologist
here's what you can know though
I have just staked my reputation on a
claim about how the immune system works
and how the vaccine as described by
those who designed it should work
if I'm wrong you Michael Shermer are
sitting here and there should be a flood
of biologists ready to explain what I've
got wrong and when that flood of
biologist doesn't show up you should ask
yourself the question why is that
Weinstein is wrong why is nobody
pointing out the reason did you invite
them on your show to talk about it I
mean I it doesn't matter you you can
invite them I'll invite them show me who
knows the answer to the question and I
I'll be happy to talk maybe I'll host
the episode of the Michael Schumer show
with you and whoever I would love that
if you want to if you want to bring all
outfit on who's the guy that uh Rogan
wanted to have back on oh Peter Peter
hotels yeah
all right so philosophically I think
this is an interesting predicament
because Michael is having the correct
reaction what you Brett are saying can't
possibly be right that there is an
obvious reason based on simple
immunobiology that invalidates the MRNA
platform because it will trigger an
autoimmune disorder if that were true
surely other people would know about it
we wouldn't be
employing these things much less
continuing to re-up boosters and
planning to put other vaccines that
weren't mRNA based onto the MRNA
platform that seems shocking to him that
such a thing could possibly be true
therefore the most the level at which a
fringe belief doesn't warrant being
taken seriously because it's too Fringe
it's too far outside there's too few
people saying it I don't have time to
deal with all the Fringe stuff that
comes my way not this one not this time
no thank you Brett right so as a
non-expert his conclusion is that just
doesn't sound like that could be right
because if that were true what else
would that imply and my point is well
strange as it may sound Michael that is
exactly what's going on here it's not
the first time that I've described this
mechanism and you know he asked me he
says uh
what do people say in response and I
said I've never heard a credible
response now that may sound even more
incredible to him what are the chances
that there's not even if it's wrong that
there isn't something that people say
well but that that question is exactly
the right one what do people say in
response and when the answer that comes
back this is not your first rodeo on
this one when the answer that comes back
is I can't get a response
now again there will be some cases where
people are
talking such craziness that they just
don't warrant a response right and it
can be hard for a non-expert who doesn't
feel like they can assess the evidence
to tell the difference
but
when you have it's not just you and me
making these arguments that you you are
specifically making a very precise
argument here but writ large there are a
lot of people who are arguing that the
MRNA platform is actually the opposite
of safe and effective yep right or the
opposite of safe
and
you're not just one guy even if you were
just one guy you have a track record
that is proven
uh and therefore should be given a
little bit more credibility going into
the question even more than that I would
say you and I were constantly berated
during covid for the fact that with the
platform that we had that are speaking
about the dangers of the vaccines was
irresponsible because people might
believe us and if they did it might put
them In Harm's Way so whatever else
might be true the fact that we have a
platform that you're willing to tell us
that we have an obligation to shut up
because people might listen if I'm
saying nonsense about the nature of the
immunobiology here then somebody should
come and say politely perhaps this is
not true and here is why and the fact
that that message never comes tells you
something and in fact I'm reminded no
and it's such a precise scientific
argument it wouldn't take much for
anyone to dismantle if it was
dismantleable right right and so I was
reminded that uh many years ago Ralph
Nader came to Evergreen and I had not
been able to reach him I wanted to talk
to him about the telomere work and the
implications for the mice because I
thought it was right up his alley
and I uh tracked him down backstage of
course I did I tracked him down
backstage and I said Mr Nader I have a
story I want to tell you I've wanted to
tell it to you for a long time and he
said okay
and I did my best
12-minute version of the story and he
asked me one question
he said
was the response that you got back
dismissal or silence I said it was
mostly science and he says okay that's
how I know your story is probably right
because that's how they do it
so anyway
interesting anecdote that he would have
seen that but here's here's my important
yeah it's an important an important
situation
um but here's what I did not realize I
think I recorded that podcast on the
28th with Michael and with Michael and
Jeremy riss
and what I only found out yesterday is
that
um John Campbell had done another in his
series of podcasts one day prior okay
and in that he describes the exact
mechanism that I have been describing he
describes it I think it's almost
identical except that he uses the term
lymphocyte whereas I he says
cytotoxic and I say uh killer T cell and
natural killer cell but the mechanism he
describes is unmistakably the same
mechanism am I right we cannot show it
Zach no
okay but interestingly not only does he
go through the same line of logic for
what must be true if the
mRNA vaccines do not stay in the deltoid
as we know that they do not where he
says look they you know the lipids on
the surface of the cells will have a
chemical affinity for lipid
nanoparticles which means that any cell
that these things encounter can take
them up and can translate them into
protein at which point the immune system
will attack the cell and destroy it if
that happens in your heart that would be
myocarditis exactly the argument I've
laid out
says he reaches the same conclusion he
says not only is this a devastating
danger for these vaccines but it will be
a devastating danger for any mRNA
platform vaccine which is what I have
also been saying so
what I'm thinking is now you know I
didn't know that John Campbell was going
to do an episode on this but now Michael
Shermer has another data point where not
only am I saying things that he can't
check but if they're true suggest a
campaign of Silence over an obvious
design flaw of the MRNA vaccines but now
he's got John Campbell independently
saying the identical thing so now
Michael should start to think what would
have to be true that nobody is telling
these two guys that they've got it wrong
okay now you know let's add uh Peter
McCullough to the list because Peter
McCullough has made a similar argument
what would have to be true for nobody to
be telling Peter McCullough that he's
got it wrong okay we can add Mark
Gerardo to that list why is nobody
telling him that he's got it wrong
um Andrew Wakefield why is nobody so at
some point you've got enough people
coming from enough different places
spotting the same design flaw that
frankly
clearly implies no vaccine could be put
on this platform until a targeting
mechanism is designed and that could be
two decades away yeah something that is
capable of targeting a tissue that you
can afford to lose
um well and I you know I will I would
love to talk to John Campbell about this
because he says a couple of things in
his description where he and I might
slightly differ about the implications
um and anyway it would be great to talk
that out uh a live virus vaccine has
this defect but it does have targeting
because you're using a live virus it's
not going to go into everything the
virus comes pre-targeted right the virus
is pre-targeted and so the point is you
could get a cost benefit analysis that
makes that a viable platform whereas
there is no rescuing this platform until
you have a targeting mechanism and I
have not heard thing one about how you
would Target it what's more they just
vaccinated billions of people with one
that wasn't targeted and lo and behold
myocarditis showed up and nobody can
figure it I mean in fact John Campbell's
video
was in response to Pfizer having been
asked if they knew why it caused
myocarditis by the Australian Congress
and they failed in real time to say
anything coherent they just spouted
boilerplate nonsense and at the end of
their boilerplate nonsense they promised
to look into the matter and get back to
them with an answer to the question and
John Campbell goes through the answer
and there's no answer in it shockingly
enough so the question is does Pfizer
know what the rest of us know and it's
deploying these things anyway or does it
somehow not know in which case how did
it Miss something so basic
this I don't know yeah so
what we need is philosophers to grab
some people by the lapels and get them
to respond to the evidence the way they
should yeah I mean I think you know to
bring It full circle to where you
started
um
there needs to be
uh like a system of keeping track
of actually I made this claim
and if it is wrong
you should want me to know that I want
to know it
this is of importance in this particular
case the entire world
and it would be easy to dismantle if
it's not true
so
the next time this comes up
the response can't once again be but
that can't be the case lots of
credential people don't think that's the
case
the answer like every time it comes up
and you want to respond with but look at
how many people think you're wrong
you have people have to start keeping
track and this is I think where you're
arguing the philosophy comes in like you
have to start keeping track of like but
if there are so many people who believe
I am wrong and actually believe that
from first principles as opposed to
they've been told to believe that by God
Pfizer or whatever then
tell me how I'm wrong
so and you know it feels like the
failure to respond is almost like this
extraordinarily juvenile woke move of
like it's not my job to educate you I'm
so exhausted like I can't do it you know
what it's science
and it's your obligation
um to actually come up with an
explanation for why your damn product is
causing these Grievous
um
problems in people and there is a
plausible hypothesis on the table that
no one is attempting to falsify that is
what science does it's attempts to
falsify hypotheses here it is all of
those people who think that uh Pfizer
knows what it's doing and the platform
is great
respond to this it's your obligation to
respond and when you don't the natural
conclusion
you've got
a an empirical observation of a kind of
damage that is dire
you've got young healthy people having
damage to their hearts damage to their
hearts that in many of their cases
compromises them in the short term in
many of the other cases we should expect
it to compromise them in the long term
that if this was an honest system in any
regard if Pfizer for example was a
company that was actually interested in
improving human health then its
discovery that there might be something
wrong with its product that was causing
young people who had a long life ahead
of them not to have a long life ahead of
them that would cause it to be very
interested in this question and when you
discover that it is not at all
interested that not only can it not be
asked in real time by uh Australians to
explain how myocarditis is being
produced but even when it submits a
written response later it's completely
empty a total disinterest in answering
that question says at the very least
that this company is indifferent to the
deaths that it is causing
it may be that it thinks there's a
cost-benefit analysis in which it thinks
it's saving more people than it's
hurting but if you were saving more
people than you were hurting you
wouldn't be indifferent to the ones you
were hurting and especially when there's
an age stratification
to be done that would save most of those
young people so the fact that it doesn't
respond in the way that a normal person
would at discovering something
surprising suggested maybe it's not
surprised at all maybe it knew this and
it's just fine with it
I think that's right
all right I think we've arrived and I
think we are there
oh we're going to take a break and then
we'll be back with a q a on uh on Rumble
only right
uh and the chat uh will be the the watch
party will be on locals only you can ask
questions at darkhorsesubmissions.com
and of course you can find us all sorts
of other places as well but we would
really love to direct you to rumble and
to locals where again we've got watch
parties for our live streams we're
releasing guest episodes a day early on
locals we've got our monthly private q a
on locals now and Discord is coming soon
so please please join us there and
Brett's began doing some spur of the
moment amas on locals uh we're both
going to become active there so please
please join us there and
um come find me at Natural Selections
natural selections.substack.com where I
write weekly about all manner of things
and you can find cool gear at our store
at darkhorsestore.org
and um
once again our sponsors this week are
Seoul biome and mudwater check them out
we are supported by you so we thank you
for your support for sharing for
subscribing for liking and for liking uh
clips and full episodes and uh we look
forward to uh having you with us next
week until then until we see you next be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]